مشاهدينا اهلا بكم هذه التغطيه متواصله
للزلزال تركيا وسوريا الكارثه التي تتصدر
كحدث اول عالميا لصعوبه وقسوه المشاهد
التي تمخضت عنها مشاهدوا انقاذ ورفع انقاض
ولحظات قليله من الفرح بانتشالي احياء من
تحت الركام بعد خمسه ايام من وقوع الزلزال
فاكثر من مئه ساعه تلاشى بعدها الامل شيئا
فشيئا بالوصول الى نجيم خاصه في ظل البرد
القارس الشديد عدد القتلى ارتفع الى نحو
24 الف شخص في تركيا وبحسب الرئيس التركي
اردوغان تجاوز عدد القتلى
19.88 شخصا واكثر من سبعه وسبعين الف مصاب
اما في سوريا اعلن المرصد السوري ان حصيله
القتلى وصلت الى اربعه الاف وخمسمائه وهي
مرشحه للوصول الى سته في مناطق اعلنت
اليوم منكوبه حلب اللاذقيه وحماوه ادلب
الشمال السوريه يضع فوق ماساه حجم الكارثه
فيه يفوق قدره الجميع بحسب منظمه الصحه
العالميه ففي هذه البقعه من الخريطه
السوريه يسكن او كان يسكن اكثر من اربعه
ملايين لاجئ اكثر من 70% منهم يعيشون على
مساعدات امميه بالاساس كانت مناشداتهم
بناء بيوت لهم اصبحت احلامهم بعد الزلزال
خيمه
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في لقاء
صحفي خلال زيارته لمدينه اديمان التركيه
ثلاث جوله له في غاز عنتاب مركز الزلزال
الاول قال ان الدوله ستعمل على مساعدتي
اقارب المتوفين جراء الزلزال واعاده
الاعمار في اقصر وقت ممكن
اود ان اؤكد لاقارب المتوفين اننا
سنساعدكم في كل شيء على المتضررين الا
يقلقوا ابدا سنعيد الاعمار بكل الطرق وفي
اقصر وقت ممكن نحن نعمل على تكريس
امكانيات الدوله لتقديم المساعدات
كلمه اردوغان تناولت ايضا تواعدا له
باتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه قاسيه بحق من
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحل التجاريه وينهبون
السلع والمواد منها وقدم اردوغان اعتذاره
بسبب صعوبه الوصول الى بعض الاماكن حتى
الان لمساعدتها مؤكدا ان الاستجابه لم
ترقى الى ما كان يريد وفق
تعبيرهم مع الاسف هناك بعض الناس الذين
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
وينهبون السلع والمواد الدوله اتخذت
التدابير وخطوات ضدها هؤلاء وستتم
معاقبتهم باشد الطرق الدوله ومؤسساتها
موجوده وتقدم كل المساعدات الى حد الان لم
نتمكن من الوصول الى بعض المناطق
لمساعدتها اعتذر نحن نعلم ان الوضع صعب
الدوله التركيه تحاول بكل جهودها للوصول
الى كافه هذه المناطق
ايضا توعد رئيس التركي هذا التواعد من
قبله جاء بعدما اظهرت مقاطع مصوره عمليات
سرقه ونهب اقدم عليها بعض الاشخاص في
المناطق المتضرره جراء الزلزال وايضا كانت
هناك تقارير صحفيه عده نقلت تفاصيل عمليات
السرقه في المدن المنكوبه
[موسيقى]
هدى
العمل جار على انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه في
تركيا وايضا في سوريا ولكن في قهرمان مرعش
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من انقاذ طفله تبلغ من
العمر 13 عاما وذلك بعد بقائها لمده 99
ساعه تحت الركام
[موسيقى]
مع مروري خمسه ايام على حدوث كارثه
الزلزال اي ما يعادل تقريبا 120 ساعه فرص
نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض تعد شبه معدومه
تعتبر اول اثنتين وسبعين ساعه اي اول
ثلاثه ايام اطارا زمنيا حرجا وينخفض بعد
ذلك معدل البقاء على قيد الحياه الى ما
بين 5 الى 10% وبحسب خبراء الكوارث
الطارئه تعتبر التنتين والسبعون ساعه
الاولى بعد الكارثه هي الفتره التي يمكن
للانسان ان يعيش خلالها بقوه جسديه دون
طعام وماء يبلغ معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه 90% خلال اول 24 ساعه وخمسين في
المئه الى 60% بين 25 و 48 ساعه فيما
يتضاءل الى ما بين 20% وثلاثين في المئه
بين 49 واثنتين وسبعين ساعه اما بعد
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه فيكون معدل البقاء على
قيد الحياه ما بين خمسه الى عشره في المئه
او اقل في الكوارث عاده ما يتم الغاء معظم
جهود الانقاذ بعد خمسه الى سبعه ايام
فالعثور على شخص ما خلال هذه الساعات
الذهبيه هي مساله حياه او موت وتعتبر
سباقا مع الزمن
الى متى يمكن للعالقين البقاء تحت الانقاض
وضعيه الشخصيه عند حدوث الانهيار فمن
المهم تواجد الشخص في مكان بحمايه جسديه
الحصول على الماء والهواء فهما اساسيان
للبقاء على قيد الحياه
ومن الضروري عدم الاصابه بالجفاف لرفع
احتماليه البقاء على قيد الحياه
بعض التقديرات تشير الى امكانيه بعض الناس
العيش دون ماء لمده تتراوح بين الثلاثه
وسبعه ايام
مستوى الاصابات
فقدان الدم او الكسور يقللان احتماليه
البقاء حيا لاكثر من يوم
خصوصا اذا تعرض الشخص لصدمه في الراس او
اصابات في العمود الفقري او الصدر او تضرر
العضلات نتيجه السحق
الظروف الجويه خبراء يقولون ان الظروف
الشتاء تجعل الوضع اسوا بكثير
السرعه التي يحدث بها انخفاض حراره الجسم
ستعتمد على مدى عزله الشخص او مقدار
الماوى الذي يتمتع به ولكن في نهايه
المطاف سيصاب العديد من الاشخاص الاقل حظا
بانخفاض حراره الجسم في ظل هذه الظروف
القوه العقليه والنفسيه خبراء يشددون على
اهميه الحفاظ على الاراده النفسيه
والعقليه المركزه على البقاء قد يكون امرا
حاسما للبقاء على قيد الحياه كما قالوا
انه من المهم السيطره على النفس والتقليل
من الذعر للتقليل من الحركه الجسديه
لتوفير الطاقه
ينضم الينا غسان بلوز مو فدى العربيه من
قهرمان مرعش حيث ظهرت اليوم بارقه امل
انقاذ طفله تبلغ من العمر 13 عاما بقيت
قرابه 100 ساعه تحت الانقاض من رصدك غسان
لعمليات الانقاذ في مركز ثاني زلزال ضرب
تركيا هل الامل لا زال قائما هل رصدت
اشارات بين الناجين وبين فرق الانقاذ
لاخراج المزيد من الاحياء من تحت الانقاض
حنين لا شيء امام الاهالي تحديدا سوى
الامل خصوصا بعد مرور خمسه ايام واكثر من
120 ساعه ويعني على اعتاب اليوم السادس
يتمسك الاهالي بالامل مع الانباء التي ترد
سواء من كهرمان مرعش او المناطق الاخرى
بان هناك ناجين يخرجون حتى هذه اللحظه
ولذلك يبقوا متمسكين بهذا الامل حتى
اللحظه الاخيره يعني في مناطق المنكوبه
والدمار الذي حل بالبلاد في جنوب البلاد
هنا هناك يعني احد الزملاء يشير لي بان
هناك خمس جثث في هذه هذا المبنى الذي يقع
خلفي حنين
في الامس كانوا يتحدثون عن
العمل الجاري حنين على انتشالهم كما
تشاهدين الان ستلاحظين بالصوره العمل جاري
على انتشالهم للاسف بالامس كان عناصر
الانقاذ ابلغونا بان هذا المبنى فيه خمس
اشخاص على قيد الحياه
واليوم نتحدث عن خمس جثث وبالتالي هو ما
كنت تشير له قبل قليل حنين بان هناك معدل
زمني للعالقين تحت الانقاذ ثلاثه ايام
الاولى وبعد ذلك تقل وتتضائل نسب النجاح
فكنا نتحدث عن خمسه هنا اليوم يقولون انهم
ماتوا وباتوا جثث ويحاولون انتشال هذه
الجثث ايضا في مبنى مقابل لهذا المبنى كان
هناك ثلاثه اشخاص
ونفس الشيء ذات الشيء فقدوا الامل بهم
ويبدو انه لا يوجد اي اشارات على انهم على
قيد الحياه وايضا انتشلوا جثه اخرى من
مبنى اخر يعني
في الساعات الاخيره في الثلاث ساعات
الاخيره ثمان انتشال اربعه جثث وما زال
العمل جاري في جميع المباني حنين نعود
لموضوع الامل الحنين كما قلت لك لكن عناصر
الانقاذ تواصل هذا العمل الاهالي
المتمسكين بالامل فرق الانقاذ تعمل ليلا
نهارا على مدار الساعه خليه نحل نحن نقف
في شارع في عشرات المنازل حنين مدمره
بالكامل يعني نستطيع القول بانها احياء
مدمره بالكامل
من الكثير من المشاهد التي تاتي من الجنوب
التركي لاحظنا ان هناك مباني مهدومه
ومهدمه بالكامل ومباني قد تضررت بجانبها
بالضبط بجانبها فهذه نتحدث عن ثاني مركز
يعني مركز الزلزال الثاني ربما الاضرار
بليغه بشكل
كامل في مدن كامله في احياء كامله بالفعل
حنين
بالفعل حنين يعني كهرمان مرعشيه مركز
الزلزال وبالتالي احنا نتحدث عن بلده هي
اشبه بمدينه اشباح لا يوجد احد حتى في
المباني التي تشاهدينها في الصوره اذا لا
ادري ان كنت تشاهدين مباني في الصوره يعني
ما زالت صامده لكنها ايله للسقوط في ايه
لحظه وبالتالي هي تشكل خطر كبير على حياه
المواطنين بطبيعه الحال
تعمل على اعاده الاعمار خلال عام وتامين
المنازل المتضررين وبناء المساكن
للمتضررين خلال عام والى ذلك الحين تقوم
السلطات بتامينهم في مراكز
الى ملكته اليها
في بدايه حديثك عن هذا المبنى قلت ان هناك
خمسه اشخاص علمتم بالامس
بوجودهم احياء تحت هذا المبنى اليوم مساء
هل هذا هم خمس جثث هل هذا يعني ان العمليه
تاخرت
حنين عفوا لم اسمع سؤال جيدا نعم تحدثت
وقلت انهم كانوا كانت المؤشرات تشير الى
ان هناك خمسه اشخاص احياء تحت هذا المبنى
واليوم مساء تم استخراج خمسه جثث هل هذا
يعني تاخر عمليات الانقاذ بالتاكيد كانت
الافاد موجوده في ذلك الوقت هل هل تاخذ
هذا الوقت الطويل لاستخراج
الاشخاص من تحت هذه الانقاض
حنين عمليا الخمس جثث ما زالت موجوده لم
يتم استخراجها لكن ما قالوه لنا بالامس
عناصر الانقاذ في هذا المبنى تحديدا انهم
رصدوا
اصوات ومؤشرات بان هناك خمس اشخاص ما
زالوا على قيد الحياه وعلى ما اذكر انهم
قالوا ان هناك اطفال بين هؤلاء الخمسه
اشخاص لكن اليوم يؤكدون بانهم لم يرصدوا
ايه مؤشرات على حياه تحت هذه الانقاذ
وبالتالي هناك خمس جثث في هذا المبنى وما
زال العمل جاري على ازاله او انتشال هذه
الجثث لماذا هذا التاخر بطبيعه الحال حنين
عمليه الانقاذ
واستخراج او انتشال
الجثث او حتى مساعده الناجين على الخروج
هي عمليه صعبه ومعقده جدا وخطيره في نفس
الوقت حنين لا تستطيع فرق الانقاذ ان
تستخدم الاليات الثقيله وتقوم بازاحه
الاطنان من
الاسمنت كما تشاهدين والركام بطريقه
عشوائيه لان اي حركه خاطئه قد تؤدي الى
مزيد من الانهيار على رؤوس الناجين
والعالقين اسفل هذا الركام وبالتالي
يستغرق هذا العمل وقت وجهد طويل وكبير جدا
حنين لذلك حنين في هذه الساعات خلال ساعات
العمل تتضاء الفرصه النجاح كما كنا نقول
ويمكن ان يكون هناك عالقين ناجين لكن في
خلال عمليات
الانقاذ يمكن ان يفقدوا يفقدوا حياتهم
نتيجه مرور ساعات طويله عليهم تحت الانقاض
ونحن نتحدث عن خمسه ايام عن اكثر من 120
ساعه حنين وندخل باليوم السادس كما تقول
حاسمه وحرجه جدا ابقى سالما امنا شكرا لك
كنت معنا من قهرمان مرعش غسان ابو لوز
موفد العربيه
مع وقوعي الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
يسعى رجال الانقاذ للاستعانه بكل ما يمكن
من ادوات وحتى الحيوانات للوصول الى ناجين
تحت الانقاض وانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه لاسيما
ان عمليات البحث خلال هذه الكوارث من اصعب
عمليات الانقاذ وتعد الاكثر تعقيدا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان يستطيع صعود درجات عاليه هو التنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
حركات خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي
يكشف عن دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن اعلى
صوته ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك
الانقاض بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول
ولا يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربي
اذا الادوات المتقدمه لانقاذ منهم تحت
الانقاض ان توفر في تركيا فهي معدومه في
سوريا وذلك يعتمد على الامكانيات زلزال
الساده من فبراير ضخم في المناطق المنكوبه
من الصعب على الناجنه فهم حجم ما حدث وهذا
ما افاد به الكثيرون في شهاداتهم لكن
مشاهدينا
لفهم ما جرى في ذلك اليوم في السادس من
فبراير في جنوب تركيا وفي شمال سوريا
سنتخيل ان سطح الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن
بازل
الطبقه الخارجيه منها ليست متصله وهي
مكونه من صفائح ضخمه 20 قطعه متداخله مع
بعضها البعض بنفس الشكل الذي تتخذه
الاحجيات وهناك اسباب كثيره
لان يكون هناك زلزال سنطلعكم على بعض منها
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هذه هي الخريطه كما ذكرنا
الزلزال في السادس من فبراير كان ضخما جدا
وفي المناطق المنكوبه من الصعب على
الناجين فهم حجم ما حدث وهذا ما تحدثوا
عنه لكن لفهم ما جرى بالضبط سنتخيل ان سطح
الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن الطبقه
الخارجيه منها ليست متصله هي مكونه من
صفائح ضخمه تقريبا عشرون عشرين قطعه
متداخله مع بعضها البعض وبنفس الشكل الذي
تتخذه الاحجيات لكنها تستمر في الحركه
وببطء وبمعدل سنتيمتر الى 20 في السنه اما
ان تتباعد او تصطدم ببعضها او تنزلق عبر
حدودها
ما احدث الزلزال الاول وما تلاه منطقيا
كان تحركا عنيفا تمزق على اثره امتداد
الصدع بين صفيحتي الاناضول والعربيه التي
تقع تركيا على خطوطه مع الصفيحه الاوراسيه
ايضا تركيا تحركت مشاهدينا بثلاثه امتار
خلال ثواني نعم الجغرافيا تغيرت البلد
باكمله تحرك نحو الغرب غير او تغير مكانه
اذا حركه كهذه مع اصطدام وانزلاق لبلد
كامل من المؤكد ان يحدث هذه الصدمه او
الاصطدام وهناك ايضا كما قلنا اسباب اخرى
[موسيقى]
فرق الطوارئ في سوريا اكدت ان العديد من
المنازل في مدينه حلب التي طلقت الضربه
الاكثر الى من الزلزال تضررت بشكل كبير او
انهارت تماما وبحسب الفرق لا يزال الكثير
من السكان عالقين تحت انقراض البنايات في
حلب التي يقيم فيها ملايين اللاجئين الذين
تشردوا بعدما افقدتهم الحرب الاهليه
منازلهم
[موسيقى]
من القى مثلي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
جمعه عكاش اهلا جمعه تحدثت سابقا وقلت انه
اليوم لم تسفر المحاولات محاولات وعمليات
الانقاذ عن اخراج اي ناجنه من تحت الركام
والانقاذ هل تغير شيء
ابدا يعني مضت 36 ساعه حتى الان
فرق البحر الانقاذ على كامل الجغرافي
الكوبى لم تعثر على اي حتى ان
تصل العثور عليهم يعني لا اقول او انعدمت
لكن هناك امل في العثور على ناجين لكن حتى
اللحظه 36 ساعه مرت ولم يتم العثور على اي
ناجين تحت على نقاط كل ما تصل اليه
الايادي فرق الدفاع والانقاذ هم عباره عن
جثث يضافون الى يعني حصيله الموتى الذي
باتت الان يعني كبيره ابنا نحن نتحدث عن
4,120 سوري قتلوا في هذه
الكارثه
والاف الاصابات رغم
ثابت باعتبار ان المئات لا يزالون تحت
الانقاض تحديدا في
بلده جنديرس بريف حلب وايضا في مدينه
اللاذقيه حيث فشلت فرق الانقاذ والدفاع
رغم ان يعني فرق من من الصين ويعني عناصر
من الجيش الروسي وايضا من فرق من الجزائر
تساعد يعني الدفاع المدني والبلديه وايضا
وزاره الصحه في اللاذقيه الا انها لم تصل
الا الى 30% من المباني المنهاره بمعنى
هناك 70% من المباني المنهره في اللاذقيه
لم تصل اليها فرق الانقاذ يعني عدد القتلى
في اللاذقيه كانت 383 ارتفع في يوم واحد
الى 508 بمعنى نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 130
قتيل وصلوا يعني الى جثتهم الى المشافي
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن ارتفاع كبير متوقع
في الاعداد سواء في اللاذقيه في مناطق
النظام او في جنديرس التي لم يصل يعني
فرقه الانقاذ الا الى 35 مبنى من اصل 84
مبنى منهار بالكامل يعني نحن نتحدث ان
هناك تسعه وثلاثين مبنى حتى الان لم يصل
اليها فراق الانقاذ وبالتالي نتوقع ان
يكون هناك عدد كبير من السوريين في
اللاذقيه وفي جنديرس تحت الانقاض ربما
يرفع العدد الى نحو 6000 قتيل في هذه
الكارثه
الجمعه انها حارم وسلقين ايضا في ريفي
ادلب من اكثر المناطق التي تضررت بهذا
الزلزال ولكن لو تحدثنا عن المناطق الاقل
تضررا من هذا الزلزال ايضا هناك صعوبه
بالغه في رفع الانقاض فيها
في كل المواقع التي حدثت فيها يعني
انهيارات في المباني هناك صعوبات لعده
اسباب السبب الاول اولا يعني افتقار الفرق
الى المعدات الثقيله سواء كانت الرافعات
او الجرافات او حتى النقارات ايضا
افتقارهم الى المعدات الصغيره الحديثه
كالمجلسات والكاميرات الحراريه والاجهزه
الاخرى التي تستخدمها الفرق المتطوره عاده
في مثل هذه الزلازل وانا اقصد خارج سوريا
يعني في تركيا ايضا هناك فرق تستخدم يعني
معدات صغيره تصل الى الجثه وتستطيع ان
تميز بين الذي فقد حياته والذي لا يزال
على قيد الحياه هذه المعدات غير متوفره
لدى فرق في سوريا لا في مناطق
كثير الكثير من الامور مفقوده في هذه
الكارثه التي حلت بسوريا منظمه الصحه
العالميه تقول ان الوضع في سوريا اكبر من
ان يحتمله يعني الوضع بشكل عام يعني هو
اكبر من قدره الجميع على التحمل وعلى
الانقاذ لكن جمعه من ناحيه المساعدات كانت
هناك مساعدات مقدمه من قبل قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وعلقت ايضا وهذا اليوم الثاني
على تعليقها هل هناك بوادر للسماح بهذه
المساعدات للدخول الى الشمال السوري
تحديدا نتحدث عن المناطق خارج سيطره
النظام
حتى هذه اللحظه المساعدات التي قدمتها
الاداره الذاتيه والجناحها العسكري فسد
علق في معبر ام جلود الواصل بين مدينتي
جرابلس ومنبج ولم تدخل هذه القافله ولم
تحصل يعني الاداره
اداهيه على موافقه الطرف الاخر من المعبر
وتقول الاداره بان تركيا تعرف الدخول هذه
المساعدات اما من باب الهوى فدخلت شاحنه
يعني قافله من 14 شاحنه تحمل مساعدات
وايضا دخلت من مرض الباب السلامه قافله
لمنظمه البرزاني الخيريه قادمه من اقليم
كردستان العراق 12 شاحنه توجهت الى جنديرس
وعفرين هذه كل المساعدات التي دخلت طبعا
اضافه الى بعض صهاريج الوقود التي يعني
جاءت من تركيا لا نعرف اذا كانت يعني
صهارين في التجاريه لان حمولتها كانت تفرق
في محطات الوقود اي انها شراء من تركيا
على ما يبدو
ايضا نذكر بان
الناجين والمتضررين من جراء هذا الزلزال
بحاجه الى خيام لم تصلهم ضمن المساعدات
التي وصلت الى سوريا اشكرك جزيلا شكرك
معنا من القامش لمراسل العربيه جمعه كاش
ومن سوريا نعود مجددا الى تركيا الى هاتاي
مفاده العربيه عمار هندي اهلا عمار عمار
كيف هي الاوضاع لديك
انا كنت استمعت لتقرير الساعه ستون عن
الاجهزه المتطوره التي تعمل في تركيا
حاليا او عموما وتساعد على معرفه او تحديد
اماكن الاحياء تحت الانقاذ هذا الامر على
ما يبدو انه احدث فارقا كبيرا حنين فيما
يحدث هنا في في هاتاي لانه
حسب ما علمت بان الناجي التي خرجت اليوم
بعد اكثر من 100 ساعه تحت الانقاض في
المبنى في المبنى الذي خلف هذا الذي
تشاهدينه الان استخدمت هذه الاجهزه لتحديد
مكانها ومعرفه انها على قيد الحياه وعلى
هذا الاساس تم انقاذها واخراجها حيه وكانت
بصحه جيده ما يحدث الان بان العمليه
اختلفت يعني التكنيك اختلف في البحث عن
الناجين هذا المبنى المنهار فيه لا تزال
حتى هذه اللحظه عائلات وافراد من عائلات
لم يخرجوا بعد وبذلك كل ما يعني يتم فعله
الان هو تفتيت
تبقى من ركام المبنى الاول للوصول الى هذه
الطبقات التي تشاهدينها لانه فيها يعني
عشرات الاشخاص حسب ما سمعنا من اقاربهم
هنالك عائله مكونه من ثمان افراد عائله
لشاب سوري وهنالك عائلات
عائلات يعني اقارب هؤلاء الذين يجلسون هنا
ويشعلون النيران من البرد لا زالوا
يتواجدون هنا حنين حتى الوصول الى اقاربهم
داخل هذا المبنى هم لم يرحلوا من هنا منذ
خمسه ايام طبعا يبيتون في هذا البرد
وسيبقى هنا لحين الكشف عن مصير اقربائهم
المبشر في الامر ان في الزاويه تلك التي
يعني اشير اليها هنالك صوت لناج وتحديد
مكان ناجن يقومون بالعمل على الدخول فتح
نافذه للدخول والعبور اليه لاخراجه على
قيد الحياه وبسلامه ولان هذا الامر يحتاج
دقه يستغ الكثير من الوقت حنين لا اريد ان
اقوم بانه ايضا اريد ان اشير الى ان هناك
قرابه يعني 6000 شخص من بين الفرق الدوليه
تساعد في تركيا في عمليات الانقاذ اضافه
الى
144 شخصا تحدث عنهم اليوم الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وتحدث عن جميع الامكانات في
الانجاز
الانقاذ عمار سنعود اليك لكن سنعود سنذهب
لسوريا مره اخرى ونتابع هذه اللقطات
لاخراج طفل على قيد الحياه في جبله
بمحافظه اللاذقيه بعد خمسه ايام
اذا هذه الصور التي سنشاهد الان تاتي بعد
ان كان هناك يعني الامل ضئيل ومفقود اليوم
لما ترصد اي عمليات انقاذ في سوريا
لاي استخراج اي من الناجين من تحت الانقاض
جميعا من تم استخراجهم كانوا ضحايا قتل من
هذا الزلزال سنترككم مع هذه الصور من
سوريا من جبله من محافظه اللاذقيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا ايضا نذكر بان جبله بمحافظه اللاذقيه
هي من المدن التي تعرضت لدمارنا شديده في
هذا الزلزال في السوق الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا وكان مراسلنا قبل قليل جمعه كاشي
يتحدث عن هذه الاضرار البالغه والان سنعود
مجددا الى هاتاي الى موفد العربيه عمار
هندي كنا نتحدث عن فرق الانقاذ وتحدثنا عن
فرق الانقاذ ايضا الدوليه التي تشارك في
عمليات رفع الانقاض واستخراج الاشخاص من
تحتها هل رصت وجود اي من الافراد الاجانب
في هذه العمليات في هاتاي
نعم نعم اليوم بالفعل شاهدنا فريق عمل
روسي ضخم كان يعمل في هذا المكان جاء هو
في بدايه الامر ومن ثم بعد ذلك انسحب
وجاءت فرق انقاذ تركيا تعمل وايضا هنالك
قافله او فريق كامل وضخم هنغاري كان
يتواجد هنا يعمل في البنايه التي
تشاهدينها التي هنالك كان صوت لاحد
الناجين تم تحديد ان هنالك شخص على قيد
الحياه ويعملون على اخراجه وهنالك ايضا
كان وفد من سلطنه عمان يعمل في هذه
المنطقه ورايناه اليوم ويعمل في في على
بعد 400 متر في بنايه من هنا هذه الوفود
كلها حنين تعمل في سبيل شيء واحد فقط ان
يسابقوا الزمن الى جانب الفرق الانقاذ
التركيه للوصول الى الناجين تحت الانقاض
اليوم طبعا نحن على وشك ان ينتهي اليوم
الخامس وهذا خطر كبير وشديد جدا وصراحه
هذا الشيء بدا يعني يبعث الياس في قلوب
الاسر والاهالي اليوم ما حدث بانه حينما
علموا ان هنالك سيده بعد 100 ساعه خرجت
على قيد الحياه كان هنالك امل كبير لديهم
ويعني انتعشوا كثيرا ولكن التاخير الحاصل
وهو ليس بيد رجال الانقاذ لانه كل
الاستعجال في هذا الامر ربما يضر هم
يعملون بطريقه ذكيه جدا وبهدوء لانه اذا
كان شخص على قيد الحياه ربما خطا واحد في
هذه العمليات يعرض حياته للخطر فيقتل بسبب
العمليات وليس سبب بسبب الزلزال
ما اريد ان اوضحوا بان رقعه الدمار هائله
جدا وقياسا بهذه الرقعه العدد الذي يعمل
والتعزيزات التي تاتي لا تزال غير كافيه
لانه هنالك ايضا حنين وهذا يبدو لك غريبا
هنالك بنايات لم يتم العمل حتى هذه اللحظه
والوصول اليها على سبيل المثال هذه
البنايه على يسار الشاشه التي ستظهر لديك
اليوم فقط بدا العمل على اخراج الاشخاص
فيها او او العالقين من تحتها قاموا بهدم
البنايه الاولى ومن ثم سيصل الى البنايه
الثانيه التي تظهر هذه طبقات المدمره
وهناك هذه العائلات التي تجلس هنا وتنام
هنا على على هذا الشارع هي تنتظر اقاربها
المتواجدين تحت انقاذ تلك البنايه نحن في
اليوم الخامس ورقعه الدمار كبيره ولذلك
الارباك الحاصل ونقص الاعداد المشاركه في
الاعمال اخرت قليلا الوصول الى هذه
البنايات ولكنهم المبشر انهم يعملون الان
يعني ولو جزئيا في بنايه ليصلوا الى
الاخرى وكما قلت لك دخول اجهزه متطوره
لتحديد اماكن الاشخاص الاحياء لعب دورا
كبيرا نعم عمار نتمنى ان نشهد بارقه امل
جديده من هذا المبنى او ذاك شكرا جزيلا
لكنت معنا منها تايم العربيه عمار الهندي
نشرت الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان تغريده
ذكرت فيها ان المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
ابو الكرتون كطالب بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
في سوريا وذلك لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات الى
ضحايا الزلزال الذي دمر قسما من البلاد
كما طالب باحترام حقوق الانسان بهدف تقليل
اثار الازمه الحاليه التي اصابت البلاد
وفي حديثها للعربيه اكدت المتحدثه باسم
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه في الشرق الاوسط
ريم ندى الحاجه الماسه لفتح المعابر
السوريه لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات المتضررين
من الزلزال هناك مخزون يكفي لمئه الف شخص
وجبات
لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع وهناك
مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف حوالي
مليون ونصف شخص ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه
ولكن تحتاج الى طه بالنسبه لدخول
المساعدات نحن
نستخدم ممر باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر
في داخل سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب
الزلزال والدمار الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطء لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب
الدمار في المنطقه
المدير العام للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
روبرت مارديني شدد في مقابله على العربيه
على ان الوضع في سوريا جره الزلزال ماساوي
ووصفه بالمساويه الوضع ماساوي جدا ونحن
باللهجه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر نتعاطف مع
جميع السوريين اليوم
يجب ان لا ننسى ان جميع السكان في سوريا
ازمه بعد تلوى الاخرى على مدار اكثر من
عقد وصولا الى اللحظه الراهنه من نزاع
تسبب في تبعات انسانيه كارثيه الى جائحه
الكوفيد 19 وازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه تفشي
وباء الكوليرا اخر سنه السنه والان كارثه
طبيعيه مع هذا الزلزال التي تقع في
الحقيقه ظروف مناخيه قاسيه جدا وحتى قبل
وقوع الزلزال هذا الاسبوع عدى النزاع في
سوريا الى اقتراب الب التحتيه الاساسيه
والخدمات العامه في ارجاء البلاد الى نقطه
انهيار وهذا هذا هذه مشكله كبيره
ياتي ذلك في ظل تعقيدات تنتشر بعمليات
ادخال المساعدات الاغاثيه الانسانيه وفي
المقابل زار رئيسه النظام السوري بشار
الاسد احدى المناطق المنكوبه في حلب حيث
اظهرت صورا الاسد وهو يخاطب مجموعه من
رجال الانقاذ في اول زياره معلنه له الى
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال كما اعلنت
الرئاسه السوريه ان الاسد زار مستشفى حلب
الجامعي برفقه زوجته الجديره بالذكر ان
القوات الروسيه المتمركزه في سوريا ساعدت
بشكل كبير خلال الايام الماضيه برفع
الانقاض مع قوات النظام في مناطق سيطرته
اظهرت صورنا متداوله انهيار مبنى في احد
احياء مدينه جنديرس بسوريا جرار الزلزال
المدمر الذي طلب البلاد
ومن جنديرس ينضم الينا مدير الدفاع المدني
الخوذه البيضاء رائد الصالح اهلا بك
طلبتم العون وانتم راس حربه الانقاذ في
الشمال السوري واخيرا جاءت رساله اقرب الى
الياس هل فعلا فقدتم الامل بالوصول الى
نجيل من تحت الانقاض
نعم فعليا تم يعني مع الاسف انه ما عاد اي
ليس هناك اي امل بايجاد اي ناجين من تحت
الانقاض ونحن نعمل على انتشار الجثث اعتقد
الى مسائل الغد او خلال 48 الساعه القادمه
نكون انهينا كل عمليات البحث والانتشار
الجثث من تحت الانقاض وسنبدا نتحدث عن
جندي
رس جنديرس وحارم وسلقين معظم المناطق
فعليا انهينا العمل بها تبقى لدينا ثلاث
مواقع الان نعمل بها هي سلقين وحارم باقي
المواقع الاتاري بالدانا سرمدا
الجيني
دركوش الرماديه عزمارين ادلب ارمناز
كفرتخارين جسر الشغور الملل هذه المواقع
جميعها انهينا العمل بها وتبقينا لدينا
عده مواقع بسلقين عده مواقع بحارم وعده
مواقع ما زالت تعمل لدينا الان 15 فريق
يعمل في جنديرس لدينا سبعه فرق يعملون في
سلقين ولدينا ايضا حوالي تسع فرق يعملون
في حارم ما زالوا
ولكن مع الاسف يعني نحن فقدنا الامل ان
نجد ناجين من تحت الانقاض الان يعني الان
تلقيت معلومات قبل ان ادخل الى المقابله
وبعدها يعني الان ستبدا عمليه انتشال
الجثث بشكل اسرع حتى يتم حتى نكون لدينا
القدره ردا على
التقييم المباني التي
تضررت الى
الهيم المباني سيد رائد الصالح فلتتفضل
بالبقاء معي سنتابع سويا هذه اللقطات
لانقاذ ام واطفالها ثلاثه في جبله في
اللاذقيه قبل قليل
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد
الاشخاص وهو على قيد الحياه بعد كل هذه
الفتره
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد الاشخاص وهو على قيد
الحياه الف الحمد لله
الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه يا شباب
ابراهيم زكريا
باقي فراش
حبيبي
شو اسمه يا شباب ابراهيم زكي
أنا أعود الى رائد الصالح مدير الدفاع
المدني الخوذه البيضاء من جنديرس الى تبعث
هذه الصور بالامل لك يعني من جبله
اللاذقيه هذه الصور لشاب ابراهيم زكريا تم
الان انتشاله من تحت الانقاض وايضا قبل
قليل كانت هناك صور لشخص اخر
لا شك انه انا يعني سعيد جدا اني ارى
مازال الاشخاص يخرجون من تحت الانقاض في
جبلي واللاذقيه
وهذا وانطاكيا وغازي عنتاب ويعني نحن
رجال البحث والانقاذ الدفاع المدني بمعظم
الاوقات لا شيء يعطينا العمل لا شيء
يعطينا الامل اكثر من شخص يخرج من تحت
الانقاض على قيد الحياه
هذا الامل الذي دائما ما نتمسك به وهذا هو
الكنز الذي نبحث عنه اصلا تحت الانقاض
لذلك يعني ولكن نحن حقيقه يعني انا هناك
تاخر كان في الاستجابه في في جبلي في
اللاذقيه في حل كان هناك تاخر لذلك هناك
اشخاص يعني نحن كنا في مناطقنا لن اقول
اننا يعني اسرع ولكن نحن بسبب عمليات
القصف خلال عشر سنوات ماضيه نحن متاقلمون
على العمل ولدينا
يعني ديناميكيه اسرع في التعامل مع بعضنا
ومتناغم
اسرع عمق يعني يبدو انه لم يتعرضوا
عن طريق مكون من 25 الف شخص اليس كذلك لا
لا نحن الفريق مكون من 3100 شخص ولكن
مدنيين يساعدونكم ايضا هناك عشرات
المدنيين حقيقه الذي ساعدونا ولكن كانوا
تحت رقابه وعمل فرق نحن فعليا فريق القوه
البيضاء في سوريا هو
3170 شخص تقريبا
باداريين بقياده العمليات بكل المسؤولين
هم يعني هناك حوالي منهم 350
امراه ايضا يعني كان هناك فرق
للنساء هناك فرق للرجال كانت تعمل وتنقذ
وتعمل ولذلك نحن حقيقه كنا يعني منذ 17
ساعه نحن لم نستخرج اي شخص من تحت الانقاذ
وكل عمليات الاستخراج كانت عباره عن اشخاص
فقدوا حياتهم تحت الانقاض ونحن اعتقد نحن
الى الغد او خلال 48 ساعه القادمه سنعلن
عن انتهاء عمليات البحث والانتشار ايضا
وليس فقط الانقاذ يعني
الجثث ايضا القت الضحايا
وسنبدا في العمليه كما ذكرت انه سيكون
هناك بدات فعليا من اليوم عمليه التقييم
تقييم على المباني عن متضرره
نعم فريق المهندسين في الخوذ البيضاء ايضا
ينسق الان مع مجموعه كبيره من المتطوعين
كون انت تعلمين ان الشمال غرب سوريا لم
يدخله اي فريق لم تصله اي مساعدات لها
بالبحث والانقاذ لم تصل ايضا الخيام
للناجين وللاشخاص المتضررين منظمه الهجره
تقول الان ان المساعدات التي دخلت لشمال
سوريا شملت مصابيح واغطيه لا يوجد فيها
اغذيه وايضا نعلم انه لم تكن هناك اي خيام
هذا الامر دعيني اتحدث عن هذا الامر
مساعدات في سوريا الى في سوريا الامم
المتحده يعني انا اسف يعني دائما ما
ينشرون معلومات مضلله السيده التي تحدثت
اثناء التقرير عن وصول المساعدات وعن
الاعاقه هي حقيقه تنشر معلومات مضلله ولا
تتكلم الحقيقه ايضا رئيس الصليب الاحمر هو
لا يتكلم الحقيقه هم لم يرسل مساعدات الى
الان الى لاستجابه للزلزال الى شمال غرب
سوريا هم يضللون المجتمع الدولي وهم
يضللون المواطنين ويضللون قنوات الاعلام
ايضا من ارسل مساعدات دعني اكون واضحا
وصريحا في هذا الامر من ارسل مساعدات الى
سوريا للاستجابه من الخيام والمواد مركز
الملك سلمان ادخل مساعدات اليوم قافله
مساعدات دخلت من معبر الحمام وهناك قافله
اخرى تنتظر الان في باب الهوى واعتقد
صباحا ستدخل قطر الخيريه والهلال الاحمر
القطري ايضا ادخلوا مساعدات اليوم من معبر
باب السلامه
مؤسسه البرزان الخيريه ايضا ادخلت مساعدات
من باب السلامه ايضا هناك جمعيات اهليه
ارسلت مساعدات
وسوريين ارسلوا مساعدات اما الامم المتحده
ارسلت البارحه ست
قوافل ست سيارات اليوم ارسلت 14 سياره
ولكن جميعها هي مساعدات مجدوله قبل
الزلزال خصتها وحددت ان هذه المساعدات تخص
الزلزالوا الى الان وانا تحدثت اليوم مع
مسؤولين في الامم المتحده وقلت لهم كفاكم
تضليلا
للمدنيين وكفائده التضليل وكفاكم تصريحا
انكم ترسلون انتم ارسلتم مساعدات للنظام
صح ونحن لا لا نعارض هذا الامر لاننا نحن
نرى اهلنا في اللاذقيه واهلنا في جبلي
واهلنا في حلب هم بحاجه الى المساعدات
ولكن ايضا اهلنا في في ادلب بحاجه
المساعدات يجب ان تكونوا حياديين في ارسال
المساعدات السيد مثلا روبيرت رئيس الصليب
الاحمر لم يرسل مساعدات الى الى شمال غرب
سوريا وهو اذا ارسل يريد ان يرسل عن طريق
النظام السوري
ان نتواصل لجيرم بهذا الخصوص قبل قليل مع
قناه العربيه اشكرك جزيلا الشكر
هو يضلل شكرا جزيلا ان كنت معنا من جنديرس
مدير الدفاع المدنيه للخوض البيضاء رائد
الصالح
قال المكلف بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون طالب تحريك المساعدات لسوريا
وتركيا على المستويين الفرنسي والاوروبي
منذ البدايه طلب رئيس الجمهوريه تحريك
مساعده الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
كجواب لطلبه قدمتها
مركز الازمات والمسانده التابعه لوزاره
الخارجيه التنسيق على الصعيد الاوروبي
الداخلي مع وزاره الاخرى المعنيه او وزاره
الداخليه من بيدها
لتقديم
مساعده الدعم ندرس حاليا
وسائل يعني بتقديم هذا
المستشفى الميداني وكما تفضلت هو قادر على
معالجه 100 الجرحى يوميا
[موسيقى]
سنواصل معكم تغطيهنا للزلزال لكن سنتوقف
امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى قال
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان هناك تزايدا
للدعوه في الغرب الى ما اسماه بتفتيت
روسيا مشددا على وقوف موسكو بحزم
والمواجهه بمستوى اقوى اكد ايضا سعيا
بلاده لتشكيل نظام متعدد الاقطاب لخلق
ظروف خارجيه متساويه للتنميه الشامله وذلك
في الوقت الذي تتزايد المحاولات للسيطره
على القضايا الدوليه والعلاقات الاقتصاديه
بشكل كامل على احد وصفه
اكد الجيش الاوكراني في بيانه اليومي ان
القوات الروسيه كثفت منها هجماتها الجويه
على مناطق واسعه شرقيه اوكرانيا وذلك
تمهيدا لهجوم بري واسع في الذكرى الاولى
لاندلاع الحرب واضاف بيان الجيش الاوكراني
ان مدينه خارقيب تعرضت لقصف مكثف يوم امس
فيما اكد عمده
ان المدينه تعرضت للقصف سبعه عشره مره
خلال ساعه واحده في محاوله الروسيه لاخماد
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه قبل تنفيذ هجوم شامل
على شرق اوكرانيا
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
تعزيز قوات الامن في منطقه القدس على
خلفيه وقوع هجوم بالدهس اليوم والذي اسفر
عن سقوط قتيلين واصابه سبعه مستوطنين في
الريموت بعضهم دخل في المراحل الخطره كما
وجه نتنياهو ايضا بالتحرك الفوري لاغلاق
منزل منفذ العمليه وهدمه بالاضافه الى
القاء القبض على الاشخاص ضل صله بالمهاجم
اصدرت وزاره الاستخبارات والحرس الثوري
الايراني بيانا يفيد باعتقال السلطات
لمنافدي هجوم اصفهان بالطائرات المسيره
وذلك وفقا لوكاله انباء تسنيم الايرانيه
والتي افادت ايضا بان السلطات تعرفت على
اشخاص قالت انهم التابعين لاسرائيل في
الهجوم بالطائرات المسيره على احد المراكز
الصناعيه الخاصه بالصواريخ في اصفهان
شددت الخارجيه الروسيه على ان النشر
الصواريخ الامريكيه التي تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت في اليابان يؤثر على الامن
والاستقرار الاستراتيجي في العالم وقالت
الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا ان
روسيا ستراقب عن كثب اي استعدادات لتنفيذ
خطه واشنطن مؤكده ان تنفيدها سيعني تغييرا
في الامن الاقليمي وكانت تقارير اعلاميه
افادت ان واشنطن اقترحت نشره صواريخ
متوسطه المدى في اليابان كجزء من خطه
لتعزيز الدفاعات ضد الصين على طول بحر
الصين الشرقي والجنوبي
حتى النرويج وسويسرا في بيان مشترك
الاطراف اللبنانيه على السماح باجراء
تحقيق نزيهن وشفاف في انفجار مرفا بيروت
والامتناع عن كل اعمال التدخل داعيه مجلس
النواب اللبناني الى الاسراع في انتخاب
رئيس يوحد الشعب اللبناني من اجل المصلحه
الوطنيه كما عبرت عن قلقها ازاء الوضع
الحالي في لبنان
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه عبر
العربيه لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا في السادس من فبراير دقائق وتكون
معكم الزميله